all right Jen yes Jen where are you from
where didd you grow up well I originally
I was born into Ritter Louisiana um but
I grew up in East
Texas um a small very small town in East
Texas um when we finally were able to
get out of that
town went to some of somewhat of a
bigger Town went to school there for a
couple of years um I'm mainly from Tyler
Texas um
but
the the article that I sent you that was
in the Dallas Observer that was kind of
the
crescendo of
everything from from when I was four
years old as as early as I can remember
and it may be even it may even be
earlier than four years old but so much
led up
to that by the
book uh right up in the Dallas Observer
and
um you want to tell us that story yeah
the Dallas Observer or when I was just
your whole yeah well I I tell you what
so I've been in counseling now finally
been in counseling for about 3 years and
I recall my
mom saying a counselor was never going
to get through her head you know she she
wouldn't be able to settle down she
wouldn't be able to relax nobody could
put her under trance or anything like
that but so much had happened in my life
along with my mom's life that I felt
like I wasn't only
dealing with my issues I was dealing
with my mom's issues and so when I got
into counseling 3 years
ago uh I was doing this specific type of
um I don't know what it's called it's MD
EMDR something like that and it started
bringing up bringing back memories
that I had shoved so deep down
inside and
um one particular memory I was I was
young um and at the time I lived with my
mom and my stepdad my um biological
father um wasn't in the picture for the
first 20 years
but I don't hold that against him
whatsoever I know um a lot of people um
hold um family members accountable for
their actions
but that man my biological father is the
most amazing man I've ever met and I met
him when I was 20 unfortunately I was
with my
stepdad from I don't know an infant
until 17 18 years and then I met my
biological father when I was about 20
but I remember I believe I was about 4
years old and my stepdad and my mom my
stepdad's name was
Jerry um Jerry go and so I will refer to
him I will try to refer to him as Jerry
um because my biological dad his name is
Terry so um Jerry and my mom decided to
open a bar um in this super small town
that we lived in and I remember going
there every day I remember seeing this
is aging me I remember seeing the Juke
boxes and the pool tables and the dance
floors and I remember as young as what I
was I could read um the Tom Collins mix
on the bar and I'm helping them fix this
this bar up and here I am four years old
and and um not think of a thing about it
and at the
time
just head over
heels as much as you possibly could for
for your dad you know I didn't know I
was too young I didn't know anything
about him I didn't know what he was
doing um so he got
that bar open
and my next
memory we
lived while that bar was open we lived
in a single wide trailer and I'm not
knocking anyone that lives in a trailer
but we had I think eight or nine people
in this single wide trailer that was
two-bedroom one bath it was myself my
great-grandmother my mom my dad my Jerry
um my
brother Jerry's
stepson and so maybe it was six but in
this two-bedroom one bath um
trailer and I remember being outside one
time and and and literally this is
when things just started going south and
I was about four or 5 years old and I
was outside we had a dog I've always
loved dogs and um he just walked right
over to the dog in front of me and just
shot the dog in the head and um I
remember crying hysterically and asking
him why did you do that and he just said
well I didn't I didn't like that dog and
um so it went from there you know some
weird things happened I mean I would
watch him
siphon gas tanks out of cars because we
didn't have any gas in our cars um but
one thing that really my counselor took
me back to
was I was I was about four or five and I
was standing at the window I was in a
chair up in the
window and a a police car car um came
into our driveway and um they handcuffed
Jerry my
stepdad and he my mom has always been my
savior always but me being so young
that's my dad and so I just remember
banging on the window not knowing what
was going on just banging and banging
and banging and I'm screaming and I'm
crying and I'm daddy where you going you
know what's going on and Mom's not much
of anything I think because she's trying
to keep me sheltered and I'm four or 5
years old
um but what came about from that was
when he opened the
bar mom my mom was in there with him and
Jerry was very jealous of my mom my mom
was just such a beautiful woman and he
did not want any man looking at her he
didn't care walking down the street
whatever so Mom was standing
there and this man was staring at my mom
and he approached my
mom Jerry just pulled out a gun and
killed him right there and
um so that's how I
think the police officers initial that's
why I think they initially took him but
um he had a really
high-profile defense attorney um out of
East Texas that that got him off that
that was it was self-defense and looking
at it looking back on it now even though
I wasn't there it wasn't self-defense
there was no self-defense because he was
a loaded gun Jerry was a loaded gun it
did not matter
um what happened what we did what was
said he was ready to go at all times we
had um all kinds of people that would
show up at our house and he would tell
me and he called me sis he go assist you
need to go inside and of course me just
being always so inquisitive I would look
out the doors and I'm trying to figure
out you know I'm not saying as a child
who the hell are these people but you
just get a feeling and
so not only did we have that going on
around us but but Jerry and this is so
embarrassing for me to say
Jerry was a a fighter he fought
roosters and I was embarrassed by that
even at that young age you know to this
day I cannot stand chickens I don't I
don't want to be around them I don't
want to hear them but um he would drag
me to these fights and um I would
you would just see the remnants of these
half dead roosters just all over the
place and it's freezing and it's 2: and
3: in the morning and and I just want to
go to sleep and I'm four or 5 years
old and sometimes nobody's watching me I
mean there's just strange people
everywhere and I'm just I I was taught
from a young age to keep your guard up
to always watch your back and so that's
what I did and we had um so we had that
going on um somehow we finally moved
from that house in jackon Ville he got
off on the charges of murder um we moved
to
Tyler and um I remember being in the
back seat of his car and all of a sudden
we get pulled
over and he gets handcuffed and the
police officer
opens my back door and he said something
like sweetheart I need you to come with
me and I started crying and I was like
you know what's going on with my dad you
know you're taking you're taking my dad
again you know and and he said look
we're going to take you somewhere safe
and so he ended up taking me to Jerry's
defense attorney's office and still to
this day and I'm 50 so 45 46 years ago I
remember sitting in like a basement area
at this attorney's office drinking a
Coke and eating pepp Farm Brussels
cookies and I've been love with I've
been in love with those cookies ever
since um but anyway he finally got out
of jail we moved into a house my
mom wanted to be um my mom wanted to be
a nurse she was very independent um and
that has spilled over into me but Jerry
didn't want that he wanted to be the
control freak and so she reg they argued
she registered herself for nursing
and he literally destroyed her nursing
books and and I remember seeing them um
just going at it in front of me it's
like they as much as I love my mom they
didn't give a damn what kids were where
I mean they were going at it and um so I
I remember being terrified but I also
remember and this was this
was brought to the surface when I was in
counseling
that um not only had I gone through this
but a lot more stuff that I will tell
you about I was
um I was molested and I was molested
from the age of maybe 4 to 7 or 8 it
wasn't by my
stepdad um
but
um I did not remember
this until the counselor started doing
this specific um EMDR on me and I just
lost it because I
thought I've had this shoved so far deep
inside of
me that here I am I've had these
children and I've had my children around
this person and then I start blaming
myself how in the hell could you allow
your children to be around this person
and I'm just beating myself up and I'm
having panic attacks and and
um they're not around that person
anymore I don't uh speak to that person
but back to
Jerry
so Jerry liked to go to pawn shops in
the area whether it be Tyler Dallas
wherever and he always demanded that I
go and I would tell him I don't want to
go and I was young and he goes no you're
going to go
and he would leave me he would take me
to some of the shadiest
places um in Dallas off of like um I30
in Monger or I30 in Carol and would
leave me um in the car for hours on end
and he and he would say this is a really
bad area you need to lie down in the
floorboard you don't need to move
um so I said okay and you and he always
carried he he carried everything in his
front pockets guns his wallet he always
dressed in all black because in his mind
he felt like he was some kind
of badass
Gambler um Mafia Hitman kind of he was
an informant for the FBI the Texas
Rangers the
local police department
um he he always took me to these
different places and I couldn't say a
word and um don't tell your mom that I
took you here but on the flip side of it
he would always dot on me he was just he
was always talking about she's so smart
um she's really going to make something
of herself one of these days
and then fourth grade hit and we lived
in this
house and my great-grandmother lived
with us and and it was his grandmother
we were there was no relation but she
was just she was the only grandmother
that I had unfortunately I met
my biological dad's mom maybe a year
before she passed and that that hurt me
really bad because I could see the care
in her heart and I had never had um a
grandparent um because my my mom's
mother was
just if you've seen that movie um Mommy
Dearest no wire hangers kind of thing
that's that's how my grandmother was
with my mom and just wake her up in the
middle of the night and
just drunk peeled up beating the crap
out of her making her get up and and uh
making her fried green tomato sandwiches
and when Mom finally grew up she goes
I'd be damned if I make another fried
fried green tomato sandwich I haven't
had a fried green tomato sandwich but
anyway so we're at this house I'm in
fourth grade and all of a sudden my
stepdad says
um hey let's I need you guys all load up
and take Grandma to her daughter's house
in
Dallas okay fine you it was a weekend
thing fine we were getting away from the
house well we came back that
Sunday and our house was burned to the
ground like nothing left thankfully our
dog was there but there was nothing left
and I remember just balling my eyes out
and being in fourth grade and thinking
about you know all of the things that
you had in there all your your babies
and your Barbie dolls and and all this
kind of stuff and it was all gone
and he didn't seem concerned about it at
all and so I kept trying to figure out
you know what is going on and so we had
to stay at a hotel for a while um he and
my mom has passed but I remember my mom
telling me that he would get so mad at
her for for merely looking at another
man that when he was
driving um Mom said that he reached over
and opened up the passenger door and was
trying to push her out as um as he was
driving and she was fighting him tooth
and nail not to not to be pushed out
onto the street as he as he was was
driving and she finally got back in the
car and
um it was always something like that so
we go from living just in this we go
from a trailer to a house out on the
lake but not really on the lake it's a
small P beam house it gets burned
down um it takes us a couple of years to
build this other house um that was in
Brownsboro because I actually ended up
graduating from Brownsboro High School
so we built this house put in a pool um
you know back then that was that was
cool you know I mean hey let's all go to
Jens she has a pool and
um out of nowhere one night he
says hey why don't you go
bowling and I remember looking at him
thinking because he was just a strange
man and I remember looking at him
thinking why is he wanting us to go
bowling but it was was slowly clicking
but not really like the dots were
starting to to come together but I said
all right love doing stuff like that a
big group of us went bowling including
my mom and
uh and and I feel like this is like a an
homage to my mom because you know I lost
her and she had so much to tell about
him and she wasn't able to able to tell
it
but because I paid so much attention and
I still do it to this day I overly pay
attention to things I'm overly literal
I'm always watching where I'm going I'm
always figuring
out staring at a person like okay that
sign right there is a sign that he's
lying or oh she's twitching her lip a
certain way she's lying or whatever so
anyway we come back I I'm the first one
that walks into a game room cuz we had a
garage and then a game room then you'd
walk out to the pool and then you'd walk
into the house and so I was the first
one that walked into the game room and
there was this random Furniture in the
game room
and I look back at Mom and of course it
scared the crap out of me I was in sixth
or seventh grade at the time and I said
Mom what's going on and she said I don't
know and so we go into the main house
and the house is just
destroyed everything stuff is everywhere
and I'm crying because I'm thinking oh
my gosh you know my house burned down a
couple of years ago now our house has
been
robbed and I look up you know we had one
of those old school entertainment
centers and I looked up and pictures of
me had been
stolen and I went to my dad Jerry and I
was like crying I go oh my gosh they've
stolen pictures of me and and he was
like oh my gosh they did you know and he
and he didn't seem too surprised about
it all and so the cops get out there
both of the the fire and the robbery I
ended up figuring out later urance
purposes um
but he was he was into uh to to Bookies
also and he was
into
using anybody body's
identification to get a seone number
like back then they really didn't check
your social and things like that back
then and so um he would use my social to
get a seone number he would use my mom's
social our phone number was always
changing and so all of a sudden we had
this electric gate in front of our our
house we lived on a couple of acres and
we had this electric gate and outside
the gate was a microphone phone and
um the microphone would go out you could
hear it in the house and he would say he
would yell out nobody
move and so really nobody would
move if it was dark outside specifically
he would say nobody move he said if you
can close the
blinds and so I'm sitting there Terri
ified wondering who is this person out
at the gate and why is my dad acting
like this well the person would
finally um back out and leave but then
we'd get phone
calls and I would answer he'd say sis
you need to answer the phone and I'm not
here and so I said okay um so I'd answer
the phone hey you know may I speak to
Jerry or whatever and I said I'm sorry
he's not here may ask who's calling he
would say his name I would have to
repeat his name and then all of a sudden
Jerry would be like oh no yeah I want to
talk to him because it
was um you know one of one of the many
people that he was in cahoots with there
was there was a big family out in Tyler
that they were a a bunch of um they were
into organized crime as well and my
stepdad was in with them and and um it
was always something going on at our
house my mom and I went shopping one
day and my stepdad was home and he got
um something set him off he got really
upset about something and came out of
the room with a
gun and initially you know he was just
doing this with it and flying it around
but then he points it at Mom and
me and
and still to this day I'm terrified of
guns because everywhere in that house
and I understand you know to each their
own with guns I actually have myself a
gun now because of things that have
happened
recently but there were so many guns in
our home everywhere you looked there was
a gun and here he is my dad pointing a
gun at me not saying a word just
pointing a gun at me and I'm 14 15 at
this time and Mom said um she looked at
me
and he turned and went into the living
room and she looked at me and she said
sis I want you to go in your bedroom and
lock the
door if you hear
gunshots don't come out of your room I
want you to go out go out your window
and just run run as far as you can
and I said but Mom if I hear that
gunshot he has shot
you and um she was like don't don't
worry about me I've got it I've got it
under
control and
um somehow she talked him out of it I
don't know how she did but she came back
into the room and she said sis
everything's going to be okay and I just
lost it because you know I thought my
mom my my
savior and I just started putting two
and two together and I remember being in
a car with him and looking at him and he
always had this certain look about him
and you wouldn't put he you would not
put my mom and Jerry
together they were like oil and
water everything about them was complete
opposites their looks um their
actions everything and um
um
Mom finally came to me and said enough
is
enough but he always said if I can't
have you nobody can have you
and I've heard so many people say why
can't you just get out of the situation
why can't you just
leave and a lot of the times when people
are in those
situations they can't just leave because
that
person like
Jerry would
say if if you call the cops I will know
you have called the cops before they get
here and you're not going to like
it and so I was just stuck you know I I
didn't know what to do um terrified
still dragging me around to different
places even as I'm getting older um my
mom
finally not got her Nursing degree and
she was working our bills um the only
way our bills were being paid was by
mom's job he never held down a job he
never filed taxes he owned a jewelry
store but he
was dealing drugs out of that jewelry
store and the way I figured that out was
I remember looking through one of our
old pieces of furniture and I found
these Brown glass
vials and I'm naive and I'm like what
the what the hell are these but he would
put his drugs in there and use his
jewelry store as a cover to sell his
drugs
um but Mom mom came to me and she said
we've we've got to get out of here and I
said Mom how are we going to do this and
and she said
um she said when he goes head of town
to fight his
roosters we will leave and mom went to
my great-grandmother who I was living
with us and you she said Grandma do you
want to visit your sister for a few days
and Grandma was like yeah sure and
so we took Mom we took my grandmother to
visit her sister and Mom and I were
running out of time and when I say we
were running out of time it was like a
movie you've seen we were literally
running out of time like he cannot catch
us doing this because if he does he's
going to kill
us it he had no regard he was going to
kill us because you can't if he can't
have you and he meant that towards me as
well if I can't have you nobody can have
you and so Mom and I just got the bare
necessities and and put them in the car
along with our
dogs and I remember driving
off
crying because I had so many memories in
that house like my mom
was this amazing person that that tried
to hide all of this from as many people
as she possibly could I cheered I was in
gymnastics I played basketball until I
broke my collar bone which I wasn't much
of a basketball player um ran track um
volleyball mom was always at all of my
events you know just trying to trying to
keep things as normal as
possible she didn't want people to know
what was going on under our roof and she
did not want people to know that really
from day to
day we didn't know if we were going to
be dead or alive
and my
brother I had an older
brother and instead of my older brother
taking that same path that I
took he took that path of my
stepdad and um I couldn't believe it
because we had always called ourselves
The Three Amigos because it was mom my
brother and myself and my brother would
play football and I was out there
cheering for him mom was always in the
stands but we had to go but we waited
until Brian had graduated because I was
two years younger than him we packed our
stuff up um we
left
and he figured out the only place we had
to go at that time was my mom's my
grandmother's
house and he called
there one minute he'd be crying the next
minute he's just going off
um one minute he's in my car this was
obviously before we left one minute he's
in my car and I said hey Dad can you
stop right here at the electric gate I
said I borrowed some jeans from Olivia
I'm just going to put him on the gate
and he was like no I don't want to stop
and I said we have to stop for the gate
to open anyway can you please just stop
and let me put the
jeans on the the brick
wall and he was in a mood and he just
took his fist and
slammed the front windshield of my car
and just shattered it
and I looked at him and I actually felt
like my mother the way I looked at him
because I looked at him and actually
said what the hell did you just
do and he said which was so odd to me
goes don't tell your mother I will have
this I will have this fixed and I'm over
here I already know that he murdered
someone um he's already
told my mom and myself if I can't have
you nobody can have you but he smashes
the front window of my car and says
don't tell your mom so I'm
like get my damn car fixed I I think I
was a a a junior at this time and then
it was right after that that Mom and I
were were able to get away so he calls
us at um my grandmother's house and and
he um like I said he's crying one minute
the next minute he's just iate
um and
so Mom somehow got him settled down and
I traveled from that small town to
Brownsboro for my senior
year it was a good and around here it's
not a big deal to travel an hour to get
somewhere but smalltown east Texas you
know normally it would take me 10
minutes to get to school but this time
it was from where I was driving it was
45 minutes to an hour one way and um but
I was fine because Mom and I were away
from him but then all of a sudden we
weren't we got an apartment in Tyler and
then all of a sudden he knocks on our
door and he goes just to let you know
I've got an apartment couple buildings
down and I thought okay here we go but
he was acting calm and it was so
calm that it was it was a scary calm and
the look in his eyes I he would get a
certain look at his eyes and he would
grit his teeth and I
knew he's about to lose it and
um somehow mom Falls for
divorce and as crazy as it sounds and as
crazy as this man
was custody of the dog was in the
divorce
decree um which he never got the dog
because he was always traveling doing
his own thing and
so Mom ends up meeting my biological
father they
reunite I reunite I unite with him and
it
was
like like it was almost like I had known
him forever
and just just him hugging me I felt safe
and I thought I never got upset but I
thought this is what I could have
had for the first 20 years of my
life but I did it I had this man that
loved to be considered a crook and a
criminal that loved to hang out with
this one particular man that would all
that would always say you want some
candy little
girl and I didn't understand what that
meant until
later and so I just you know I was like
okay you know uh whatever so my mom and
my biod dad Terry get back together and
I'm literally over the
moon mom never said a negative
word about Terry and I feel I feel bad
cuz him Terry now cuz he's my dad I mean
I don't know what I did without him the
first 20 years of my
life and I don't know what I would do if
I lost him because he's just been such a
rock for me especially when I when I
lost my mom um but they get back
together they move to Garland which is
like a little suburb outside of
Dallas
and by this time I'm living in Dallas
I'm working at a law firm I was waiting
tables and then I was working at a law
firm right
upstairs and Mom calls me
hysterical and she goes you're not going
to believe what just happened and I was
like Mom what calm down and and she said
she was at this store and she went to
drive I'm sorry she went to walk across
the parking lot it was kind of like a
Walmart almost like a super Walmart back
then
um but I think it was called Hypermart
but she went to walk
across um the parking lot and she told
herself just leave your gun in your
purse you don't need it well all of a
sudden a car just comes barreling her
way and she sees it and it had really
dark tinted windows he liked all of his
cars to have really dark tinted windows
he didn't want anybody to see
in he Slams on the brakes he jumps out
of the car he he grabs her he had been
following her he grabbed her and he said
get in the car and she said I'm not
getting in the car with you and and Mom
said
that she thought about her kids and she
was like if he takes me I'll never see
my kids again and so she was fighting
him and he took the gun he was pistol
whipping her um but somehow she got away
from him um she ran into the store and
within a matter of 5 minutes you would
have thought that a bank had been robbed
and because of his rap sheet he had a
rrap sheet a mile long that involved
organized crime and robbery and uh
assault with a deadly weapon and
and that murder wasn't on there that
particular murder wasn't on there
um at the time but he got away so then
she starts getting
calls and the calls they hang
up and she's telling me she goes sis I
need you to be really careful she said
I'm telling you Jerry's around and and
he's watching and I said okay so I
switched that particular restaurant job
and started working at a different
restaurant and I was at the the bar area
the server bar area to pick up my drinks
and um he was so sneaky and I just hear
what are you
doing and
just just this heavy feeling and I
recognized the voice and I looked over
and he was right
here and I said I'm I'm working and um
he said okay and he just gritted his
teeth at me and gave me that certain
look and I remember going to my manager
and
saying that is my stepdad out
there and I need someone to keep an an
eye on him I need you guys to make sure
that he
leaves this restaurant that he doesn't
mess with anybody's Vehicles
specifically mine
please I need to be safe because I don't
feel safe right now and so they were
able to get him out well then Mom starts
getting more and more
calls and mom and my biod dad Terry end
up moving to West Virginia I believe my
dad got a a ra a raise or something a
promotion and and they moved and
Christmas time my dad Terry by dad
bought mom a new car for Christmas and
within a
matter of a couple of weeks her phone
rings and it's
Jerry and he said I know you got a car
for
Christmas and just spit out the VIN
number the license plate everything spit
fit it all out I know what it looks like
I know where you live and so she's she's
calling me again hysterical and I was
like Mom you know just just come back
home you know because I'm in
Texas at the time by myself and she's
there my brother is in Huntsville he was
a a prison guard um and so they move
back home they build a home
and
mom gets a
call from an FBI
agent and he said
Debbie
um I just want you to know there's a hit
out on
you and you need to leave you have got
to get out of there
and she said if he wants me I'm not
leaving I'm tired of running cuz she had
been running she'd been running from him
her whole life and
dodging you know dodging this and
dodging that and and
um so he got wind that Mom was
notified about the hit and so something
happened with that that was finished mom
went to
Dallas mom went to visit um her mother
in East Texas and on the way back she
got pulled over by a State Trooper
and by the time she got home and this
was before cell phones by the time she
got home she had a phone call from Jerry
that said you got pulled over at mile
marker XYZ you were driving whatever in
a whatever and Trooper so and so gave
you a
ticket and she was just like I I can't
get away from this man you know I how
how is this happening how are the cops
not catching him because she's
constantly calling the cops calling that
if FBI agent that had helped her that
had told her that there was a hit out on
her and um and I'm just sitting here I
don't know I I don't know what to do and
so I told Mom I was like Mom just come
to my house and he goes he knows where
you live she said he knows where you
live don't think he
doesn't so I said okay
well I was at a
park um in Garland that same little
suburb outside of Dallas and I was on
this running trail and when I see
numbers or letters if I really focus on
them I'll remember them for years and
um I was running up this last I don't
know eighth of a mile it was an uphill
and I see my car there and I see another
car there and it's a man in the car and
I just felt uneasy about it and so I
look
at the license Li plates and I keep
looking at the license plates and I
remember the license plates I get in my
car I start to leave and he starts
following me and I thought oh my God
it's my stepdad it wasn't my stepdad in
the car but it was just somebody that he
had paid um you know or maybe that
person owed him something you know or
maybe he went to that person and said if
you don't do this
if you don't do this I'm going to kill
you and
so I stopped at a gas station called
Mom and I told her about it and I said
Mom this man is following me I said I'm
not making this up and I said hang on a
minute and I put the the the receiver on
top of the pay phone and I went around
the corner and he was making a U-turn
coming back my way and I said Mom he's
coming back and she said get in your car
and just go and and so I did I just
drove until I could get away from him
and man did she scold me even as an
adult she was like damn it sis don't you
ever do that you don't need to go
running by yourself you know he's crazy
blah blah blah and I was like all right
Mom I'm
fine it
wasn't I don't know how long this guy
had been following
me I was back at that same Trail months
later I swear I swear it felt like a
year later and same area I was running
up that last eighth of a
mile
and I see the same damn
car in the same damn license
plate and people people you know some
people are like oh I don't believe it
how do you do that but that's just that
was one of the things that my stepdad
actually taught me to do was just that
you
focus on what feels wrong you put it in
the back of your head and you never for
forget about it and so that's what I did
and sure enough the guy came out and he
started following me again and I got so
mad that I pulled into an Albertson's
parking
lot and he pulled in he left a space in
between us he pulled in beside
me and my mom came out at me I just I
got out and I was banging on his window
and in the back seat for all of these
cameras with these high power lenses and
stuff like that and he he's looking in
the back seat and and um he rolls the
window down and he goes can I help you
and I said why are you following me and
he said ma'am I'm not following you I'm
a married
man I said I didn't ask you if you were
a married man you've been following me
this is the second time I've caught you
following me what is why is Jerry making
you follow
me and he just couldn't do anything he
just sat there and I said well I'm
telling you right now I said don't let
me catch you following me again so
anyway the cops finally find Jerry he
gets 5 years for aggravated assault with
a deadly weapon on my
mom and so then it was quiet it was
quiet for a little bit like we didn't
hear much the only thing we heard was
there were warrants out for him in East
Texas and back in the day there was a
show you know like you have Wheel of
Fortune but on this particular um TV
station news station they would have
will of
Misfortune and and it was all these
criminals in the area that had these all
these warrants out for their arrest and
it wasn't just Petty crimes the these
were
felonies and they spun the wheel and it
landed on
Jerry and so then I've got people
calling me about this as soon as I
graduated high school I got the hell out
of the small town
because I was worried about the the
stigma and I didn't
want people to
think that that was me and that that's
what I was associated with but it ends
up that nobody knew like I hid it so
well my mom hid it so well my stepdad
came to me one time and he had a couple
of thousand dollars and he goes I need
you to put this in your purse and take
it to school and I was in junior house
and I said why am I putting a couple
thousand dos in my purse I'm in junior
high why why and he goes I just need you
to hold this
money I'm naive okay sure I don't know
who he ends up getting it from me that
that afternoon but and I I know I'm
bouncing around but I start remembering
these things but I remember one time I
was in the car with him and he said um
he goes hey you want to help me out with
something
and I knew it wasn't good and I just
looked over at
him just like my mother because I had so
much of my mother in me and I just
looked over at him and I was like what
and he said well I
know um I know this man who's building a
home the slab has been poured but
there's this specific spot in the slab
where he has buried a lot of money and
he said I want you to sit on one end of
the street with a
walkie-talkie and he said I want your
brother to sit on the other end of the
street with a
walkie-talkie and Jerry and a couple of
his other friends were going to
Jackhammer the concrete until they found
the money and I said absolutely not I'm
not going to do that there's no way in
hell I'm going to do that and so he was
mad at me for that for a while but it it
it was it was a daily it was a daily
Occurrence at the house and um so I was
sitting at a law firm he had been in
jail I sitting at a law firm in Dallas
and my mom called me about 4:30 one
afternoon and and um she said are you
sitting down I'm like of course I'm at
work I'm doing my legal work I'm sitting
down and she goes um Jerry's on the news
and he
um has been charged with murder of a
25-year-old
lady who had a 5-year-old
boy and I
just sat there I mean I just I I
couldn't believe it
because he had tried to kill my mom he
had people coming after me and then when
I saw the picture of this young lady she
looked so much like my
mother when my mother was younger so
then I don't hear much much of what's
going on I go to one day of the trial
and it was the the day that the medical
examiner was on the stand and the
medical examiner it didn't have any
pictures of Stacy it just had the
outline of her body and where all of
these bullets had gone in well I walk in
and Jerry looks back at me
and I don't know if he didn't recognize
me which would be wild because I looked
just like my mother um which my mother
was was there with my dad and so so I
listen to that I listen to Just bullet
wounds all over one bullet went through
here and came out there um but we had
recess for that day Mom and I went to
the bathroom as we're walking outside
Jerry is sitting there in the in the
patrol car the sheriff sheriff's depuy's
car and there's one deputy there that's
guarding
him
and I just I just get sick because I
think I don't think these people realize
how crazy this man is and so I walk past
him and we're in the parking lot away
from him and something tells me just
turn and look at him and I turned and
looked at him and he was looking at me
gritting his teeth and I could see him
doing his eyes a certain way and
then our eyes were locked in and I'm it
was like he was sucking me in and then
the car started to
leave and as the car started to leave he
moved from one window to the next and
just stared me down well then all of a
sudden he gets convicted of murder
sentenced to um basically life I think
it was 35
flat
um but then that was when we find the
write up in
um the the magazine in Dallas
where I lived right off of 75 in lovers
where the dart cop pulled him over and
Mom swear he was coming after me but I
really don't believe it but he
um uh he was caught with all kinds of
um fake uh driver's license in his
pocket when I was little I used to watch
him make fake driver's license he would
boil them apart and make them and so I
would watch that and um so they pul they
pulled out a driver's license they
noticed this foul odor in the car they
ran um the registration it came up to a
missing young lady
and so
then Dallas gets on it but then he just
starts rambling about stuff in the
background talking about we just had to
do it it you know we just had this
packed we were just going to go out
together go out in a blaze of glory and
um so
anyway he ended up with a Texas
Ranger he requested a Texas Ranger and
um someone else and he showed them the
body and they took they you know they
took the body he admitted to it of
course everything
um but
then he was in they put him in
prison there's something I was going to
tell you right there but the dark cop
ended up getting arrested even though he
did everything by the book and that's
the name of the write up and the Dallas
Observer is by the book this dark place
Poli officer did everything by the book
but because Jerry was in so many
different organizations you know cuz he
was talking about the the murder of the
uh judge harelson it was like Woody
haralson's somebody connected to Woody
harelson and how he was in on the Bion
crime family and um so anyway he was in
jail I'm thinking everything's fine
um I I I go to spend a weekend with a
couple of my girlfriends and and one of
them I had known since fourth grade and
her parents came up
and I was hugging on them and her dad
said I need to tell you something and I
said what and he said um he said Jerry
came to me one day he said he parked his
car really far away which was not normal
for him because he always wanted a quick
getaway from any anywhere restaurant
whatever and he said he came to me and
said will you dig me
a septic tank hole without the septic
tank and this man said absolutely not
cuz he knew what Jerry was all about and
so this man figured out that Stacy was
still in the trunk of that car and Jerry
had bought 20 bags of ice to cover her
body and then when he couldn't stand the
stench
anymore he just dropped her off and
covered her up with tin well then so
we're thinking everything's is fine
everything's good well then my mom
starts going
downhill she's diagnosed in August and
we lose her in October of the same year
and I just became so enraged and I
realized that every
person that I had a long-term
relationship with was exactly like Jerry
had his
traits manipulative
narcissistic um beat the crap out of me
U all of a sudden show up you
know and they were there I would show up
and they're just there looking at me um
making me shoot guns my stepdad used to
make me shoot guns my most recent
husband was like you're going to shoot
that gun you're going to shoot that gun
and I was like I don't want to shoot it
and he goes you're going to shoot the
damn gun and I shot the gun with just
tears running down my face and
um he died my stepdad died 12 hours
before his birthday in
February and the relief that came over
me but still I had the rage because he
lived a couple years longer than my mom
and I was like how dare you live longer
than my mother when she's been through
hell you put her through hell and I just
lost myself I just went into this
rage went into counseling and
um
finally have gotten back to the Jennifer
that I thought I
was that no longer looks for the person
that is going to manipulate that's going
to say
words and
um I still I I have horrible dreams all
the time about him standing over me
standing over me with a gun holding a
gun to mom's
head and I don't know when those will
ever start stop
but um I'm hoping they do but the Silver
Lining to all of this I guess is that
after being around my biological father
for so
long I have met a
man that is so much like my biological
father that when I figured it out I just
cried because Terry my dad is just such
an amazing person with just this Heart
of
Gold and here I
am meeting with this guy that I've known
since fourth grade and
now I can finally put it all to rest you
know I I can put my stepdad to rest I
can I can put my mom to rest even though
I don't want to but Jason the guy that
I'm seeing that I've known since fourth
grade he said I was talking to your mom
on Facebook one time and she said Jason
you and sis will get back together one
of these
days and I don't know if that was right
before she
died but I just wish I could give her a
high five because I know she's smiling
down on me and and just saying sis I'm
so proud of you because I could have
easily people have said why didn't you
go left you could have easily gone left
you could have easily gone the route of
drugs and just giving up and but my mom
was like it doesn't matter the
circumstances you bust your ass and you
make something of
yourself and now as I sit here I'm
director of
operations
of a company it's an intellectual
property company and we have all these
patents and I'm the director of
operations and I never would have
thought that I would even lived to be
and here I am and I just wish my mom
could see
me they say she can see
me but I hope he's rotting in
hell because it's taken
me 50 years to finally be happy and to
finally
find my true
love and basically to end
I don't want people to think
that I'm too old you know they're too
old there's always time to change the
narrative I thought I would just
steadily continue to find the same
person over and over
again and finally I didn't I saw what I
was doing mom steadily talking to me and
she's like sis you got this I I I know
you've got this you're not going to find
that same person again you're you're not
going to find this person and that
person and then all of a sudden Mark I
had a dream about this Jason guy that
I've known since fourth
grade called him up and we've been
together ever since and he's the most
amazing guy and he's just
like my biod
dad I'm no longer looking for men that
are like my step
dad that are manipulating
me and so here we are I go back home
tomorrow and I go back home to Jason and
we have five kids together we don't live
together
but if only I could have my mom standing
in front of
me giving me a hug and saying sis I'm so
proud of you you've busted your ass
you've worked so hard you got through
Jerry and all of his
it change the
narrative it's never too
late to change the narrative and I don't
think people understand
that and
so anyway the the write up is in the is
in the Dallas Observer it's called by
the book and people can read it and and
um by no means do I have the worst story
the craziest story but that's what I
went through my whole life and nobody in
school knew about it everybody thought
oh they're the rich
kids they do everything we weren't rich
kids we were poor I remember counting
out pennies and nobody knowing
it and hiding from
people and now I don't have to do that
anymore now I actually feel safe at 50
years old I feel
safe and it's because of my dad Terry
and my mom still looking over me from in
heaven if people believe in heaven and
sometimes I've wondered if damn it if
there was really a
heaven and now here I am the happiest
person even though I'm crying it's like
I'm happy tears but sad tears and
um anyway we can just end it at that cuz
I could keep you moral of the story is
be careful who you
marry be careful who you
marry it's not easy to get out of
situations when people say if I can't
have you nobody can have you that's
nothing to be laughed about that's
nothing to be to be taken
lightly and it's never too late to
change the narrative that's what I
always tell
everybody it's never too late and so
here I am at 50 finally
happy all right Jen thank you so much
for sharing that thank you Mark thanks
for having
me a hell of a story yeah yeah I guess
so
that